baseball you're a baseball fan I know
you're a big sports fan big baseball fan
6/4 manager okay well listen now we have
this issue of who's gonna get to the
Hall of Fame and they're not people like
but letting people like Bonds and
Clemens in because obviously of a
steroid use in the past what's your take
on that I don't know as I said is it is
me no I know I don't mind that people
use roids
I think they should use roids because
they're using themselves as guinea pigs
and it'll all trickle down to us one day
and after they messed up you know their
heads get all big and they take that
part out I think but I mean I think that
if enough athletes
you're saying you steroids by themselves
with steroids they'll figure out they
already you if they do it with singers
if a singer can't sing she gets to use a
steroid Yeah right
how do they fight your girl you say it's
going to improve it's gonna improve the
drugs so that we get to use I'm saying
by the time we're 80 they're gonna have
like a steroid vaporizer that you can
just inhale and you're gonna have abs
I'll get a full head of hair and you're
gonna be banging some hot 65 year old
and it's all going to be because of
these athletes and the sacrifices that
they make that no one appreciates
[Applause]
crazy like horse tranquilizers you came
out with like a mane didn't have a mane
no one had a mane people would argue
that alright so you're not you don't
have a problem with that at all ok you
want more of it I think Barry Bonds was
a victim of the steroid era because I
feel like he wasn't cheating and then
everybody else cheated and passed him
and now the president was calling them
so he was like I deal with you this is
me on roids mark here's 73 why not how
fun was baseball when everyone came up
like the Bugs Bunny cartoon remember he
played all those guys they were just
cranking him out it was amazing
it's a 7080 home run so it's good for
the sport I love it yeah I'm a what
about is it true that you are you're
kind of pals with Lance Armstrong is
that true I got to know him cuz of your
show because I came out I stuck up for
him saying he wasn't the only guy doing
it it was everybody in the race was I
can't remember what the hell I said I
would say stupid things and I went to
Austin yeah and I ended up he came out
to the show and he had it you know if he
had self-deprecating laugh about it oh
so you well you hung out with him you
become pals with them well so where you
going with this this it feel very a
couple of podcast it's been good okay
all right are you making me all nervous
I'm not making you nervous Aaron I got a
question so you hang out with him yeah
how do you guys feel about Muslims at
the airport yeah
you